قصتنا الرياضيه في ايام كاس العالم
نتوقف وتتوقف الحياه العاديه لدى كثيرين
يصبح الحديث الاوحد مباريات المونديال
وايام التي لا تتكرر الا كل اربع سنوات
هذه الايام التي تحمي الخصوصيه هذه المره
بالنسبه للمقيمين في منطقه الخليج العربي
لاسيما الدول المشاركه في المونديال حيث
يصبح التوفيق بين العمل ومتابعه المباريات
صعبه كل ذلك يدفع الكثير من الموظفين
والعاملين في مختلف شؤون الحياه الى طلب
اجازه او الغياب عن الحضور الى العمل في
سبيل حضور المباريات هذه الغيابات
المنزليه
العامه حيث تنخفض في هذه الايام بالفعل
الانشغال شبه الكلي الكاس العالم
ومبارياته المثيره
على كل اللي علقوا هذه الارقام عن
الانتاجيه في زمن كره القدم لك على
بالارقام
77 بالمئه من موظفين فقط الخليج يخططون
لمشاهده بعض المباريات على اقل تقدير ايضا
واحد واربعون بالمئه من الموظفين في دول
الخليج المشاركين في نفس الاستطلاع يخططون
لمشاهده المباريات اثناء ساعات العمل 16
بالمئه من الموظفين المشاركين بالاستطلاع
خطته ويخططون ايضا للسفر من اجل متابعه
مباريات كاس العالم في قطر واحد من كل
السته اشخاص هنا المشاركين في الاستطلاع
قالوا بانهم سيشاهدون المباريات سرا اثناء
العمل عبر بث الانترنت المباشر على كل حال
من الاردن سالنا الناس هل يؤثر المونديال
على انتهاء انتاجياتكم في العمل فانتادا
[موسيقى]
طبعا اه بعد اربع سنوات
شغل بعد الاربعه خلص روح ما بدك ما في شغل
نهائيا بصراحه مبسوط عشان ناخذ راحتنا
ونعطل ونحضر براحتنا ههه
بالله عليك
الوقت حقيقه ما باثر وبعدين مش كل
المباريات لازم تحضر بس المباريات اللي
فيها فرق لها قدره على انها تعطي كاس يعني
تعطي انطباعه الفريق بيلعب كويس
[موسيقى]
والله المونديال الاثر في طريقه سلبيه
تعرف كل يوم او كل يوم بعد يوم يكون في
مباريات وكل يوم بكون في حوالي خمس ست
مباريات يعني ليكون مباراه بتاخذ منك ثلاث
ساعات
ثلاث مثلا خمسه 15 ساعه اذا كنت متابع
يعني بشكل كبير والله الصراحه اكثر نسبه
كبيره على الشعب وعلى كل الناس يعني كل
الصراحه همم
واحد ارجنتيني وواحد اسبانيا
فيعني بشكل عام هو راح ياثر على الكل اكيد
المباراه
[تصفيق]
للمزيد ينضم الينا من جده طيران السنبل
مستشار التطوير القيادي والاعمال يسعد
صباحك يا طراد المونديال موجود لكن
انتاجيه في خطر هل بالفعل مباريات كره
القدم اثرت على انتاجيتنا في العمل
شفتي مثلا في استراليا واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه
الساعه 1:00 ظهرا في توقيت قطر والمملكه
تكون انتهت ساعات الدوام عندهم يعني
الدراسه عملت على الموظفين اللي يعملوا من
الساعه 9:00 الى الساعه السادسه انتوا
استثناء طبعا انتم تصحوا من خمسه الفجر ما
شاء الله
تبارك الله
على بدايه المباراه
فالفكره انه حسب الدول يعني قطر قلنا اللي
ما تاثروا تماما استراليا واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه
21 ساعه عمل تقريبا دول الخليج اللي بتاثر
واكثر مننا في اوروبا بعدين انا على الدول
اللي
سنغال وبريطانيا وغيرها اكثر الدول تاثرا
امريكا الشماليه والجنوبيه والجنوبيه اكثر
الدول تماما لانه على بال ما
يبدا فالانتاجه هناك عندهم الكره
القدم هذه اول اول خطوه النقطه المهمه كيف
ممكن نستفيد من هذا الموضوع اعجبني جدا
انا كنت في الرياض قبل كم يوم قابلت
مجموعه بريطانيين يشتغلوا في بروجه اكبر
المشاريع الحكوميه وريني فيديو للديجيتال
في الحيه التقني في الرياض اللي في وزاره
الاتصالات ومجموعه شركات تقنيه عاملين في
المساحه الخارجيه شاشه كبيره جدا جامعين
فيها كل الموظفين اللي اوقات المباراه
يعني فانا كسبت مره ثانيه لانه ثلاثه
ارباع الناس بده يروحوا يتفرجوا واللي
باقيسين في الدوام نتفرجوا جوالاتهم يعني
كده كده متاثيره خليني احول الموضوع
توقفتني هذه النقطه احيانا مش مهم وجودك
بس قالبا كمان لازم يكون عقلك موجود في
المكان يعني انت عم بتشوف هلا هاي الفتره
الناس ملهيه يا لابسينها التيشرت المنتخب
اللي عم بيشجعها يا قاعدين عم بتناقشوا في
مباراه امس وتوقعاتهم لمباراه اليوم
الجميع مشغول او ناس عم بتصرخ بس يدخل جول
هل الافضل انه يكون في شهر اجازه مثلا زي
ما عملت بعض الدول او الدوله المستضيفه
مثلا
العربيه
الفكره في الموضوع انه كيف ممكن يصير
الموضوع بطريقه اخرى يعني الان في شركات
كثير تعمل بعض الاكتيفيتيزول بيسموها
الفعاليات شفتك في انستغرام
هذا وقتها يعني هذا الشركات همم
قبل اسبوع تقريبا عاملين 2- يعني جيمز
رائعه يعني التفاعلات الجماعيه عاملين
حاجه اسمها هشام يعني بيسويها مثلا
كل المجموعه يجتمعوا وكل طاوله يكونوا
مسؤولين عن مهمه يعطوهم ادوات وانت تسوي
الان الفكره كلها انه هتبني مسار تمشي فيه
الكوره الين نهايه الطاوله فكيف تسير
الكوره بشكل سلس وسليم الموعل منها
والفكره منها هذه الجيم انه كلنا نؤثر على
انتاجيه الشركه وتحقيق رؤيتها اذا اي شخص
في اي مكان اثر سلبا على على انتاجيه
الشركه حيث اثر الانتاجيه الكامله بالشركه
فتخيل كيف بيكون شعورهم كلهم وكلهم شايفين
انه اللي انا بعمله كيف ممكن يصير وفي
جواز عاملينها همم مسميينها همم سدكم همم
يعني على اسم الشركه عامله دولارات كده
بيلعبوا فيها يعني مين هيجمع اكثر ويشوف
الفريق وشوف الحماس وشوفي بلاقيك انت عايز
انه خلاص الناس كسرت الحواجز بين وفيه ناس
ما بتشوفيهم الا في الكورسات وفي الدورات
وفي الاشياء هذه الزملاءكم اذا ما تعرفي
عنهم شيء اول مره يطلع صوتك في حاجه ثانيه
اسمها كاتن ذا كود كل جهه تعمل كود يدوروا
مسابقات فيها ارقام هذا وقتها يعني لو
صارت بين الاشواط لو صارت بين المباريات
لو صار في المكان نفسه في همم في فيرج
يعني مشروبات وماكولات انت طلعت بيئه كسرت
حواجز عملت الفا في فريق العمل زادت
الانتاجيه غير الناس اللي ممكن تعتمد
عليهم في الاون لاين يعني الكون علمتنا
كيف نستخدم
الامريكان وسوره البريطانيين يوم واحد على
الاقل بيعمل اون لاين فكيف ممكن الاشياء
اقسم باها تتعامل فيها اون لاين في
الاوقات اللي خارج العمل اعطيك اجازه
بعطيك وقتك تستمتع نستمتع مع بعض في مهام
معينه ابغاك تخلصها خلال اليوم تعال نرتب
جدولك بنفسك وانا كمان يعني بقول خلص
الانسان ترجع على الشخص نفسه الحريص على
شغله اللي عنده مسؤوليه اللي ملتزم ما راح
تفرق معه مباريات ولا مباريات
افرح العرب والمسلمين في كل مكان وردات
الفعل
يعني
هذا الشعور
السعاده في العالم اجمع خلينا نسعد ونطلع
منه فائده
شكرا جزيلا لك